[Music]
stick around to the end for a preview of
my experimental film labyrinth ion
available now
[Music]
the shot you see unfolding behind me is
the opening shot of a documentary that
in many ways changed the way i think
about film as a medium and to some
extent i would say also changed my life
or at least the way i see the world
when you watch this shot it's not
immediately obvious what you're looking
at you know something significant is
happening this is not a small occurrence
or event but it's not clear what it is
it's a mystery created by the
composition of image alone and sitting
and watching it unfold gives you a sense
of discovery
[Music]
it turns out to be the launch of a space
shuttle something that is visually
impressive but which at this point has
almost become mundane to us
by framing out the context that clues us
into what we're looking at we get to
feel the power and visceral gravitas of
the moment
we can see past our preconceptions to
the pure sensory detail of the thing
itself
[Music]
now it's time for an introduction
let's talk about a category of film that
doesn't get talked about very much it's
often treated as boring maligned as to
abstract to obscure or artsy or is just
entirely unknown to people but it's a
category that contains some of my
favorite films films that have
influenced my work here on youtube and
the kind of filmmaking i'm interested in
pursuing outside of youtube it's a
category that by its nature is hard to
define
some of these films don't feel like they
should belong under the same umbrella
but that's the beauty of it it's a
category of films that in some way or
another all challenge our assumptions
about what a film and even a story can
be
and i think it's an important category
that has had a strong but mostly
overlooked influence on much of the
video content we watch today
ladies and gentlemen by way of
introduction this is a film about
trickery
how do you convey the magnitude of the
human population in urban environments
in the modern world to someone
you can use words and say things like
the population of new york city is over
8 million but our basic inability as
humans to really imagine that kind of
scale means those words are almost
meaningless
photos of new york city might help and
being in new york city probably gives
you the best impression but even being
there you see only a small slice of the
population at a time
our perspective is usually too close to
feel the entire scope or too zoomed out
to really get a sense of the actual
humanity
what about conveying the magnitude of
the population of the country or the
world
koiana scotsie the 1982 experimental
documentary captures the feeling of this
scale in a profound way
in the film humanity becomes a flow
it's not just these amazing images that
give you this sense it's their duration
and for me as i sat in this flow
watching an incomprehensible amount of
people fly by for minutes on end i felt
like i was seeing a fresh aspect of what
humanity truly is for the first time
koyanascotsi is a movie with no words no
dialogue no voiceover it's just a
montage of images set to an amazing
philip class score
most people classify it as a
non-narrative film but i think it still
takes you on a journey
you travel around the world and through
time as it takes you through modern
humanity technology and
industrialization
it's a story that can't be truly
understood through exposition or words
it's a story that can only really be
grasped visually
koyaneskatsi gives you a vision of the
world that i would strongly argue cannot
be produced with any other medium
writing photos painting and performance
all have their strengths but none can
convey the same thing this documentary
is able to convey it genuinely changed
the way i think about globalization
society and the environment
and samsara a similar film from 2012
manages to touch on a feeling that i've
only ever otherwise gotten from
traveling to foreign countries
the feeling you get from the film isn't
quite as potent but it's impressive that
it even conveys that at all while only
requiring two hours of your time in your
own home versus days and thousands of
dollars in travel
[Music]
now
[Music]
reality tv is a huge part of our media
landscape for better or for worse but
its roots ultimately lie an experimental
documentary when french filmmakers in
the 1950s started to experiment with
pointing cameras at their friends and
everyday people to try to capture
conversation naturally
what they called cinema verite laid the
groundwork for what would inspire shows
like mtv's the real world which in turn
paved the way for much of modern reality
tv
some of the most stunning footage i've
ever seen in any film fiction or
non-fiction
is in werner herzog's lessons of
darkness
the film focuses largely on the kuwait
oil crisis but as if these events on
their own weren't incredible enough
herzog elevates them to an almost cosmic
biblical proportion by surrounding them
in a fictionalized context
in herzog's film he uses images taken
directly from reality but he tells a
story not of an isolated event but of an
apocalypse
such was not since men were upon the
earth so mighty and earthquake and so
great
and the great city was divided into
three parts
and the cities of the nations fell
but does this poetic narrative that
herzog uses to frame this real world
footage make the film a fictional film
does it change the reality of what we're
seeing does it make it not a documentary
herzog doesn't want you to be able to
brush these images aside and honestly
they're difficult images for me to even
grapple with
i mean forget for a moment the fictional
sci-fi dystopias from the far future or
the alternate universe grungy versions
of modern cities that make up most of
our blockbuster films and try to wrap
your head around these images from the
actual world we live in
they're terrifying and if you really
contemplate them they can take you to
the brink of an existential crisis
herzog by putting these on film is
asking you to confront this reality and
if we drop the defense mechanisms we
have to try to keep us from really
seeing the magnitude of these images for
what they are
it feels truly apocalyptic
speaking about this film in the
minnesota declaration herzog malign
cinema verite director saying
cinema verite confounds fact and truth
and thus plows only stones and yet facts
sometimes have a strange and bizarre
power that makes their inherent truth
seem unbelievable
there's a deeper strata of truth in
cinema and there is such a thing as a
poetic ecstatic truth
it is mysterious and elusive and can be
reached only through fabrication and
imagination and stylization what others
see as herzog's fictionalization herzog
sees as a route to revealing a deeper
truth
one that simply presenting the facts in
context blinds us to
but what of films with no framing
musically or from voice overs or
interviews
a film like the 2012 documentary of
leviathan can show us just how
subjective image alone can be without
any interviews dialogue or music just
using cinematography and editing
leviathan constructs a portrait of a
fishing vessel in a way you've never
seen it before as an almost mythological
monster
the power here again isn't how the film
re-contextualizes something we're
conceptually familiar with and instead
confronts us with the sensory detail of
the thing
in doing so it becomes
grotesque
experimental documentaries have always
been interested in the place where these
lines start to blur they are conscious
of how the very act of documentation
introduces subjectivity
like the if you see cars going by you
can integrate that into the general
action if you want to or you see an old
lady walking the dog here's no lady well
i don't understand what to say about i'm
who's supposed to be in charge of the
actors i mean filming the actor you and
i are going to be filming the actors i
mean the two of us don't come into my
shop i'm going to be filming the actors
william greaves wanted to explore many
of these ideas through the documentary
form with his bizarre outrageous film
symbio psycho taxiplasm take 1. in this
documentary greaves directs a crew to
film the same fictional scene performed
over and over again by different actors
while simultaneously directing a
documentary about both the creation of
the film and the creation of the
documentary that by itself is a trip but
the film really takes an interesting
turn when greaves seemingly incompetent
direction which is perhaps intentional
on his part causes the crew to revolt
and film scenes all on their own now the
director does not know that we are
photographing you know this scene we're
doing it on our own this leads to an
exploration of the audience's inability
to really know where the line is between
what is and isn't manufactured drama in
a documentary
for all anybody knows you know
bill is standing right outside the door
and he's directing this whole scene
nobody out there knows whether or not
we're for real in some sense the power
and danger of documentary is that it
purports to be conveying truth while
ultimately being just as susceptible to
manipulation and manufacturing of
narrative as traditional narrative films
five years after william greaves made
symbio psycho taxiplasm orson welles
would explore these same ideas in his
expertly crafted labyrinthian
documentary f for fake during the next
hour everything you hear from us is
really true and based on solid facts
where he draws a metaphor of the editor
as a magician able to bend reality by
making things appear or disappear at
will
[Music]
the opening shot of scott barley sleep
has her house is this eight minute
unbroken long slow pull back from a
waterfall
sleep has her house is one of those
films that really bends our idea of what
can constitute a documentary and even a
movie
by all means it doesn't seem like it
would be a documentary but it's been
classed as and won awards as a
documentary in film festivals and you
can certainly make the case for it as a
documentary of sorts it's mostly images
of nature it's a mood piece that relies
on natural imagery and so where is the
fiction really
what part of this is unreal
you might be wondering why anyone would
watch something like this and i would
classify a film like this as something
closer to a sort of guided meditation
rather than a traditional narrative
experience and i think there's a
definite value in that kind of
experience
there are very few times outside of
movies where i've sat in silence and
simply absorbed images of nature for
over an hour uninterrupted and if you
allow it to be that can be a profound
and interesting experience especially
when contrasted against the pace
and hyperactivity of most of what we
consume these days
there's a feeling this film gave me that
i've only ever had in one other scenario
one where i found myself sitting
stranded alongside a river in the winter
with a wrecked canoe and wet gear
sitting by a fire trying to stay warm as
night was falling and i was waiting for
help
some of this will probably sound
pretentious if you're not into this kind
of thing but people who are trying to
find the extreme boundaries of what a
medium is capable of i think needs some
kind of pretense to their work
it's them imagining that the form can do
something more than what it's normally
used for they're testing it and breaking
it and discovering new interesting
territory in the medium some of us might
enjoy going on that journey with these
artists and some of us might not
but all of us have benefited from the
pioneers at the fringes who have often
been the ones discovering the techniques
that then work their way into mainstream
filmmaking as part of the everyday
narrative toolkit that audiences come to
accept
much of this has very deep roots in film
history in the 1920s soviet filmmakers
were placing a lot of emphasis on the
simple power of juxtaposing images as a
means of communicating ideas filmmakers
like sergei eisenstein saw the primary
language of film as a poetic and visual
one
constructed through the connection of
images and editing and i think
filmmaking as a form has yet to realize
the full potential of what he envisioned
for it man was a movie camera is an
experimental doc directed by zika vertov
where you can clearly see how the story
of a community can be constructed
through image alone the film has a
direct connection to films like koyana
scotsie and i think it's these strange
kind of non-verbal documentaries that
are often devoid of traditional
narrative that can help us really
understand the power that images alone
have to convey ideas and when we
understand that power we understand the
full depth that cinema can offer when
words and dialogue are added it makes
sense to me that i love these kinds of
films in a way video essays are just an
extension of the documentary tradition
and for documentaries which are usually
shot without scripts the editor gains an
even greater significance as a
storyteller in shaping and crafting the
story from mountains of gathered footage
documentary is less of a genre and more
of a creative practice and approach to
the form
one where more often than not the story
must be discovered instead of created
for me these films reveal the power
available to filmmakers as storytellers
simply through removing or changing the
context surrounding an image of crafting
a narrative simply by connecting images
and editing
and the possibility
of pace as a means of meditation or
communication
these are the films that can tell
stories that are global or cosmic in
scale that delve into the architecture
of memory or that explore the very
nature
of what we mean when we say something is
true
[Music]
so in 2020 my friend ben and i inspired
by these kinds of strange experimental
films decided to get together with no
concept script plan or story and start
shooting and just see what emerged we
shot a bunch of strange footage over the
course of a week and i spent another few
weeks editing it all together it was
truly an experiment and it was a very
fun process of discovery what came out
the other side is labyrinth ion
labyrinth ion is a film with no dialogue
it's a little over an hour long and in
it an object is discovered in a mountain
neighborhood and the movie takes you
within that object to explore a world of
microscopic and cosmic scale it was fun
to make and if you allow it to i think
it can take you on a journey i learned a
lot about editing in the process of
trying to craft a sense of story out of
the most abstract ingredients you can
rent it now on vimeo on demand where you
can purchase a high quality downloadable
digital special edition from my website
a special edition comes with some bonus
features like a commentary track that
talks about how we made it which i think
is really interesting because what some
of these images actually are in real
life is kind of surprising and
fascinating check it all out with the
links below and here's a short preview
of labyrinthine
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you